two welcome everybody to a very
special i would say a it's kind of a
christmas
special except i feel like this is the
christmas that tears the family
part so it's like well we're used to
that now
it's not a merry christmas it's a uh
unmerry christmas to you because today
right right that's of course our first
lady
uh thank you for that zach let's just
get right into
divisive politics right out they gave
today's episode is sponsored by liquid
iv
and harry's we have back with us dr drew
and dr young who administered the
personality test to me trisha
on frenemies they've administered a
personality test
to all of us here to dan
zach ian ela myself a b lena
also a b butt she's not here what's the
deal
athena's there wasn't enough time for to
submit lena's
okay oh hello i have a feeling she's
probably fine
so if i had a hunt but so so here's
here's the interesting wrinkle now dr
young
one of us is apparently off the chart is
that right
uh that's correct
let's stop with the pejoratives off the
top
well one of us scored higher than trisha
correct
[Music]
on some of the dimensions but not on the
income
oh okay so this is what was the fbi
we should got the narcissistic
personality inventory
top score what she wanted she's looking
for that yeah she was
exactly so um this is very
interesting so we've all been trying to
guess who's the psycho
among us before you get to who's the
psycho i i have to respond to
the friend the frenemy show that went up
yesterday social media is going a little
crazy
um so dr joe
dr jew first of all hold on you just got
out of a colonoscopy we need to
i literally the reason i'm in like a
is i literally left the hospital here's
my eyepiece oh my god
wait here's my i still have my i still
have my
stupid tag on did they tell you the
results or you have to wait are they
like your ass looks
like i know it's all good oh that's good
that's
good
it's called lynch syndrome so i have to
get these on a regular basis and
mine this was meant so far but i
promised you guys i would try to come in
here and i was telling ethan before the
mic's heated up that
the colonoscopy felt very much like
yesterday's show just a moment
let's go but but
the uh reaming continues on social media
you should know
so i read the comments and dr drew is
being eviscerated in the comments yeah
yeah yeah
well actually compared to what i'm used
to getting on social media your your
fans are actually kind of
pleasant but anyways what do you get up
to because they're going [ __ ] wild
i'll tell you they're fine but the the
note is and i understand why they feel
this way
is that i wasn't validating your
feelings and i was quote siding with
trisha right
and in a way i was i was trying to get
you
remember one of the original goals when
i first came on the show was to help you
understand and manage trisha right right
right yeah yeah no so i was doing more
of that
and to be fair i mean she has some stuff
and she's been very open about it and it
requires
an approach and it does and if you don't
if you don't use that approach which is
you know a certain kind of containment
things spin out of control very easily
so well no from i will say from my
perspective and all the guys also here
in the studio
i did not expect that reaction yeah i i
was here after they finished and um
everyone was saying it was so
great and then we were all surprised by
the comments i i was surprised that
everyone was
that the comments and i i feel like i
understood that that's what you were
trying to do
yeah yeah so did you one thing do we
need do i need to help you in any way
support you do you need i feel like you
like no i'm fine
i want to say i felt that ethan was
really
handling her very well on that one
episode where things
blew out of control i think basically
what it was is that he was
trying to explain my position he was
he i feel like he's totally fine and
i do think we learned a lot from that
episode with you about
trisha because we actually get along
really well now
so yeah i think um it was just
the miscommunications they kind of go
out of control
those little and if you remember ethan
yesterday i was trying to get you to
withdraw
from some of that you know to know when
to get get out don't don't escalate
things
right anyway so we're good yes we're
good
yeah yeah yeah no no no of course i
never i was surprised by that i
i understood what you were trying to do
and i wasn't at any point like
this dr drew doesn't get me and he's
just nutritious i wasn't feeling that
you know you ever need me from here yeah
okay so that so thank you for clearing
that up yeah guys be easy and poor
doctor dude he just had a camera up his
ass
and well sort of two days in a row so
yeah three days in a row man come on
give the poor guy a break
[Music]
okay so now in our mets
is someone and forgive me for saying
this doctor is
off the chart psychotic oh god no
now we're trying to guess we're trying
to guess who it is okay so
what for example would the
characteristic be of that person like
how do i
define it well so basically
the doctor we took three personality
tests
no two right sorry two we took two
personality tests
one of them is a determinant of
narcissism
and then ela's worried i don't think
it's you but you was worried
and then the second one is called the
dark
triad see i learned a lot from the last
episode
which basically is narcissism
psychopathy and
uh mur and uh machiavellian which is my
favorite basically like this person
might murder someone
yes okay no no don't let's not do that
[Laughter]
it is essentially again we we went to
great lengths yesterday
yeah i don't i don't want to be too
repetitive yeah because i'm sure
everyone watched it
yeah but basically you know
machiavellian is is like cunning it's
like
uh cunning you know uh
manipulative stuff like that so that's
just the one so the first one
let's first start with the the
narcissism okay so
did anybody score uh
high on the narcissism test and then i
want to try to guess who
it was uh yes
in addition to trisha who got a 30 out
of 40
there is one person who got a 28 out of
40.
and there's another person who got a two
outfit
two two whoa is that even possible how
can you be so
selfless i've actually never seen a two
i feel like they're lying though seen a
five i've seen a five and i actually
worry about those people i feel like
they don't have a healthy narcissist
right either well do you do you ever
wonder if somebody's lying on this test
because it too
seems outrageous
well you know some people say that they
try to second-guess
you know the the answers to make
themselves
right come out a certain type of way but
i think the
survey is designed in such a way that's
very very hard to do that for every
question especially under some kind of
time pressure
so what we try to do is to tell people
just write down your first
emotion you know the thing the thing
that the answer to that resonates with
you
immediately and that's what we try to do
okay so we have
one narcissist and we have one
[ __ ] why would they well i'm just
trying to
make it like like super self-hating
self-loathing
is how would you characterize someone
with a two on narcissism are they a
[ __ ] are they self-loathing
how can we demean them
well i don't think it's a question of
demeaning them i think that
that um you know these are just seven
aspects of human behavior yeah yeah yeah
yeah tell me about how do we demo
tell me like what what would be a
personality defect of someone with a two
he he he may have trouble with
self-deficiency
i could see and uh leadership may not be
a great
quality right maybe hardly just leading
other people
uh you certainly you're gonna have
issues not even issues but you don't
feel great about your body and showing
it that time
okay this is really interesting so on
the
high so i think we all suspect zach
is gonna be the narcissist
by me just because
you get up to the weird [ __ ] bro you
just get up to the weird i've heard ab
being thrown around in sierra too
i would suspect e a b of being the uh
the simp really for bach of better words
the two the two no
i think maybe ian no ian's crazy
no i think ian's normal speak up what do
you guys think
what am i here passing judgment on
everybody well i because i
organize all of this i know the answer
and so i don't feel like i should really
chime into too much for a lot of fear of
giving it away i am should we say uh
what trisha's guess was
yeah sure she guessed you ela yeah of
course she did
she went straight after you maybe i feel
like i feel like i
so don't understand myself that i could
i worry that i might be both of the
options like
no you're not the two oh maybe
because i hate looking at myself
but i think i i have a lot of
contradicting
opinions interesting in my mind
so i wonder if i'm either one you could
be one of the two anomalies which is
insane
maybe we can break hers down mark show
her the different components okay
well let's all take a let's all take a
guess and then let's break down
zach ian i'm a b i'm forcing you guys to
to take a guess well in terms of the two
i mean hila mentioned on a previous show
how we're both kind of self-haters
right and also how she just described
herself as kind of how i feel
very similar like i feel like i could be
either way so
i kind of feel like me or else the two
and then the narcissist
is uh it's zach my boy zach for
[ __ ] sake but what what's the evidence
for that what
everything i mean i can't explain
everybody knows it's you
and since the moment that i uh mentioned
that this was the case zach i want to
point out that you've
said nothing but that it's definitely
you i wanted to know
my shrink on standby you know like well
hey that's you know what i mean we're
not here to treat you we're just here to
call you out
ian why are you not saying anything he's
the narcissist well because i'm selfless
you think you're the two i mean i'm i'm
kind i'm
loving some people refer to me as the
stop well really the patron saint of the
podcasts
i i give i give everything of me to
others
i think is normal
take a serious guess that's my guess
so you think you're the narcissist no
you're no you're no
i think i'm i'm the selfless kind all
giving you're the two
yes i think ethan's the narcissist no i
already did
i i already did this yeah actually ethan
yeah because he we
we revealed his results with trisha
yesterday so oh i guess maybe we should
have made that clear i was a seven right
is that right doctor
seven on what out of 40.
out of i should also tell you guys that
there
are three people ethan's one of them who
have scores
under eight wow there's a two there's a
five
and there's a seven yeah interesting so
this is a very low
self-esteem crew here
sounds about right that sounds about
right and one of us has enough for the
rest of us
so how did we make it this far
we don't know so tell me so before okay
so what's the average
score uh the average the national
average is
15. well we're very low so
so let's start with um
let's start with who got the lowest all
right are you ready
i'm here right what was it ian
not the lowest i knew it wait
he's he lost ian you lied on the test
no why do you think so
because i feel like he's not that
insecure
or i don't i don't know if it
necessarily means insecure or something
but i just feel like
he's really he
he's just such a you have so many
redeeming qualities i feel like you
should be more narcissistic
ian's gonna be narcissistic for you yeah
wait wait wait you're telling me i i
don't like myself
i mean that's what it seems to say
although you do have a lot of issues
with like the sleepwalking and
everything and you caught coved
obviously so tell me on the
tell me about i feel like i am not
surprised
because i unfortunately do see
a lot of um uh insecurities i guess even
though i don't agree with them i think
ian is great
i think he's and he's very talented so
tell me skip
something a great great guy yeah but
he's not you see it's more that he's not
interested in using those abilities to
get something from the world
what did that mean so here's the saying
as you pointed out
mark if you remember uh our our lowest
score amongst celebrities was that uh
child actor what's his name fred freddie
frank you mean this frankie nunez and
and he was a very nice guy and just a
you know very but
very self self uh
um you know a good sense of himself and
was not that didn't have low self-esteem
he just wasn't
needing things from the world so what is
the lowest score you've ever seen
the two two but two is the lowest i've
seen
wow ian you are the lowest score we've
ever seen on this
test so tell me which points did he
score on tell me the two that he uh
so he scored one point on
authority and one point on
exploitativeness yeah let me hear that
one what was the question
so the questions were for authority
i like having authority over other
people
or i don't mind following orders
and he likes having authority he knows
the authority
over other people interesting and then
on
uh the exploitativeness um
he's the question was i can read people
like a book
i love that question or people are
sometimes hard to understand
so he chose reading like a book so
you're you are perceptive
so this throws a wrench in my whole
theory now because
i thought ab was going to be the two and
now
really now i'm really confused let's
just jump right to
the narcissist wait when you say a b i'm
not sure whose name that represents
well abs the guy a b wave and the
cardigan
[Music]
some surprises with you so keep keep
going
[Laughter]
okay well let's let's go right to the
the narcissist
let's see who scored the highest all
right well
um the second highest score with a 28
out of 40
is jack we knew it
we all knew it zach you narcissistic
piece of [ __ ]
we [ __ ] knew it okay
okay one too many tick tocks my friend
okay
i you just think you're so good looking
don't you
no i i'm deeply insecure about myself
from there and you
think you should get all the girls don't
you no no no no i i
the truth be told i'm deeply insecure
about myself my body image
so so ethan listen to that that that's
part of narcissism
you have an inner core
this is why there should be sympathy and
not okay i'm kidding we love zach
no that's here let's hear it though i do
want to there's a very tender core that
they protect
by putting a pseudo self on top of
themselves that they get
to feed themselves to protect the core
right
and that's really how i think of
narcissism
so a little bit british is more on the
borderline thing so there's other stuff
going on
but i think zach just described really
what i think of his narcissism
he just said he was insecure for christ
okay go ahead let's hear where his uh
let's hear where he where he scores off
the chart for us yeah
okay so um on authority he got a five
out of eight
um on superiority he got a five out of
five
oh wait read those questions
a five out of five on superiority zack i
love it
yeah so superiority
the question were when people compliment
me i get embarrassed
or i know that i'm a good person because
everybody keeps telling me so
you know that reminds me that soul
reminds me cause zach always tells us
anecdote how when he goes to the grocery
store he's
asked the cashier how's her day going
and he thinks that makes her day better
and we all it does and we all laugh
because we're like she doesn't give a
[ __ ] if you ask cows or day
you gotta you gotta put a smile on
someone's face
okay keep going doctor young all right
um the next question i am no
better or no worse than most people
or i think i am a special person
i think you're a special person well
thank you
clearly so do i
the next question is compliments
embarrass
me or i like to be complimented
i mean that's fair we all like to be
complimented
some more than others
uh the fourth question is i wish someone
would someday
write my biography or
i don't like people to pry into my life
for any reason
you want a biography zack i would love a
bio
[Laughter]
what's the storytelling well he's a
young man he's got a lot of life to live
yeah
the fifth question is i am much like
everybody else
or i am an extraordinary person
[Laughter]
i mean yeah you are extraordinary we
love you you can play guitar you're
funny you're beautiful
well thank you but not the heartthrob
yeah we zach i'll have you doctors know
was recently
dethroned as the podcast heartthrob
he was replaced by ab as the podcast
heartthrob by a 75 percent vote
now how do you guys think do you think
zack is going to be coping with that
well
because those two are friends and i'm
wondering if that's going to be causing
friction between them
well i think you should take another
poll next week and see what happens
after this episode
well let's continue so superiority he
got a perfect score
and let me give some some some results
on the other side
given what jack has just said on vanity
he only gets a one out of seven
okay and on exploitativeness
no questions at all no no marks on that
interesting
so what what do you mean by that you it
means you're not
exploitative person he's not ex
exploited a person he's he's not out to
use people well yeah that's nice
he's just a sweet narcissist yeah he's a
very nice narcissist
he thinks very highly of himself but
he's not trying to uh
burn the world we like that about him
and also on entitlement um he only
scored the three out of six
huh you know i'm relieved it wasn't you
either
i know me too i was getting worried
because i
i don't know what i'm kind of curious i
want to ask about because i feel like i
have like such contradicting thoughts
sometimes like on one hand i can think
oh i'm talented and then on the other
hand i can think i hate everything i do
and i'm just like awful so
i was wondering if i'm on either side
can we review ela's results on the
narcissism scale
sure what did so let's get a drum roll
what did you score
let's take a guess so you said 15 is
normal
everything is average 15 is average okay
hit me with that drum roll drum roll
thank you all right ela your score out
of 40 is
[Music]
i mean obviously not as selfless as me
but that's really nice okay nice let's
be nice
i feel like you shouldn't feel bad about
that zach because you scored
high on like self value but low on
exploitative i think that's very nice
yeah
yeah dr drew explained yesterday that a
lot of these metrics
you know some of them are positive or
potentially positive traits while others
are
more negative and you did it sounds like
you scored higher on the
more positive self-confidence ones yeah
i i
i'm here to because you guys have a
tendency to put you know
uh valence on these we make everything
bad
in judgment who failed the test yeah i
know
so tell me where ela uh strayed from the
enlightened path would you please doctor
well you know it's interesting ethan
because um
her scores are kind of distributed
across
five different categories and there's in
no particular category is she high
so i would say that the ones um
where she got a little bit high i guess
is
um exhibitionism she got a three out of
seven
really what is that it's like what you
like to be seen and look at
really yeah really read me the one she
she flops on there
i'm so interested exhibition is amila
that's a
i don't know could that protect
absolutely good because obviously i just
think of that as a porn category
i mean right doesn't everybody i don't
even know the word so i don't even know
i was thinking of her art to be like i
mean
recognized and fashioned and ever i mean
yeah i mean i was thinking about porn so
okay when are you not what
what might not so um so here are the
three questions
related to uh her scores on
exhibitionism
the first one is either modesty doesn't
become me
or i am essentially a modest person
so wait which so which one did she
answer because those are kind of
great it's a great example of how it's a
forced answer right
very similar but one is a predictive
value in the other that's interesting
so which one did she answer she answered
modesty doesn't become me which is kind
of like an
immodest answer right
not yet honestly there might be a little
bit of an english barrier there yeah
yeah
yeah because i still even right now
don't really
completely understand the difference so
modesty doesn't become he's like i'm not
i i'm
oh well the saying i'm not a modest
person
ah whatever what's the next one
different to me a little different it's
like i'd rather not be a modest person
because it's not attractive on me
see i don't think i understood that so
what's the next one let's let's see
all right so the next one is i would do
almost
anything on a dare or
i tend to be a fairly cautious person
what
you would do anything on a dare i did
not
that's what she answered i would do
almost anything on the dare
interesting that's kind of bizarre i got
a couple dares i'd like to
ask you about later
i want to smell fit i'm trying to think
about
it i mean i guess i guess i don't i
guess you are kind of i'm not really a
cautious person i don't think
right i was about to say you have to
think of it in contrast to the other
options you probably saw that and you're
like well i'm not a cautious person
yeah i wouldn't describe myself as a
cautious person would you
i think it's complicated got to pick
like the better option
right that suits you so the next
question
is i don't care about you fads and
fashion
or i like to start you fed sometimes
well
sure that one makes sense because she's
a fashion designer
so it's it kind of struck a little bit
too close to home
so so those are the three um questions
of which
she chose the narcissistic choice
interesting
um and again kind of looking through
you know the survey there's really
nothing else that
that pops out as being significant
uh she got a two out of eight on
authority a two out of seven on
superiority
uh and then a two out of seven on
self-sufficiency see i was thinking you
would hit the authority
one higher because you seem because ela
is
a the ceo and creative director of her
own company
and i would assume and i you seem to
handle authority
fairly well and dictating to people i
think
i i think i do but i don't like to see
myself as
i like to see myself as part of the crew
like even with teddy fresh i like to
think of myself as like i'm
in the trenches with them she's feared
by her employees
she rolls with the iron fist but i in my
head i don't think of myself as like
uh i got the i don't know so
she is the prince she's both feared and
loved
to go back to the machiavellianism see
how she
scored on those on those brands yeah
that um so is there any other
you said there's something interesting
about a b that yeah how did a b
score all right let me just turn to that
look at ian sitting there all
enlightened i know
how do you feel about your score ian
he's our little buddha
i'm not surprised and those sunday
services really got to you huh
you're not surprised really no
no are you going to stick i feel like
you're doing [ __ ]
i guess you'll never know maybe
ab hit just about the national average
he got 14 out of 40.
ah okay
there are two areas i guess three where
he got some points
um for authority
he got a five out of eight oh maybe
uh self-sufficient to take over the show
so sufficient he got a four out of six
and then entitlement he got a
three out of six okay tell me about
entitlement
well by the way doctor young can i ask
you what does it mean that ab
thought he got a two
well i guess his self-perception is is
different from the way that
that he answered things when when kind
of put on the spot you know sometimes
very hard you have a feeling about
yourself
but when you're asked very specific
things
perhaps something else comes out do you
know so i'm gonna say
it's it's part of the misconception of
what narcissism is
that you guys reacted to when zach
articulated the feeling
associated with it i think that's what
we're seeing here and in fact
you'll see on some of the upcoming
uh the other tests see my brain is not
working very well i just said anesthesia
um ab has some other interesting
narcissistic
uh let's go but again
but it often feel you often feel small
and insecure
when you're interesting interesting
okay we are going to go to a quick break
and we'll be right back
with our doctors and our psycho staff
liquid iv boy i love liquid iv
and ila i don't think you've actually
tried it but i am liquid iv game
here's the three flavors of life you've
got the immune support
the orange you've got the energy drink
the green and then that one is the
hydration
electrolyte mixture which one would you
like to try i want the hydration
you do i want the energy i want to get
[ __ ] napped
i always feel thirsty oh yeah no so that
so apparently
that is supposed to hydrate you more
than water itself
it's pretty epic so basically you you un
schmutz the top you peel the top off
you pour it in so this is the the energy
one's got caffeine
it's got all that good [ __ ] that you
look for and
energy i don't have anything to stir i
just didn't i'm just gonna use this
i can't i mean i didn't think this
through very much but
the point is you mix it up
and it tastes great and i get charged up
you know
i don't like coffee if you thank you
coffee is so acidic it really messes my
stomach up
so this is basically hydrating beautiful
water
with all of the benefits of coffee this
is really loud kabuto
sorry but with all the benefits of
coffee
and it's tastes great
[Music]
and gets you charged up really good
so when i'm hungover or i eat like a
really salty food sometimes you can't
i feel like you can't quench your thirst
and so i drink the hydration one
and i feel like it really satisfies my
thirst
so they've got a formulation for every
need
i love it it's liquid iv i hate ivs
love liquid iv you know what i mean
don't want a real iv love the liquid iv
get it that's pretty epic
you know one serving of liquid iv
provides the same hydration as drinking
two to three bottles of water alone
really yeah they've got three delicious
flavors
guava juicy guava crisp watermelon
and comforting apple pie also contains
five essential vitamins
more vitamin c than an orange as much
potassium as a banana
much healthier than sugary sports drinks
because there's no artificial flavors or
preservatives
and less sugar than an apple
[ __ ] apples sugary ass [ __ ]
it's also made with clean ingredients
non-gmo vegan and free of gluten dairy
soy
it's good to go boom
did you know that liquid iv has donated
over 6.7 million
servings globally and response to covet
19
products are being donated to hospitals
first responders food banks veterans
active us military
over 3 million servings so far so this
has medicinal
value
couldn't charge up over here shoot me
out of a cannon
liquid iv is available nationwide at
walmart and beverage sections or you can
get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
code h3 at checkout
that's 25 off anything
you order when you use the promo code h3
liquidive.com get better hydration
today at liquidity.com
promo code h3
[Music]
this is how i feel you hear this music
this is how i feel when i use
harry potter no i walk into a room i'm
confident
i go hey girl look at that you want to
go you noticed something about me
cleaned up my neck cleaned up the
[ __ ] neck beard oh
don't shave my face but if i did there's
only one razor i would use
you know it's harry's
hairy's razors let's go baby it's smooth
and slick like the
what do we call this uh this isn't
really bluesy is it zack or is it blues
this is a blue shuffle like a blue
shuffle
listen it gives you the closest shave
the smoothest glide the most competitive
price
it's convenient they send it right to
your drawer what more do i need to say
about harris razor.com
h3 new us customers can redeem a harry's
trial set by going to harry's dot com
slash h3 you'll get everything you need
to feel as good as this music sounds for
just three dollars
honest value they were founded by two
friends who
are tired of paying overpaying for
racers they thought the big brands were
over designed overpriced and out of
touch
so they founded harry's as a return to
the essential
quality blades at an honest price as low
as two dollars per refill
german engineered blades
quality you know these guys
they wanted to sell product they'd be
proud of so they raised a bunch of money
to buy a razor factory in germany it's
been honing precision
precision razor blades for over 100
years they source the steel from sweden
they own the entire manufacturing
project process
this allows them to make a great product
to keep the prices low
um you hear that music i probably i'd
glide that [ __ ] razor right over my
shaft and i won't even think twice about
it
that tells you everything you need to
know about hairs new
sharper blades harry's is delivering the
sharpest blade ever and they aren't
raising the prices
their new blades are so sharp the guys
shaving four times per
week report that with harry's new blight
blade
their eighth shave was just as smooth as
their first
they've got a quality guarantee they
confidently stand by their blades with
100
money back guarantee harry's dot com
slash h3
they're available online and in stores
harry's is now available
wherever you shop so here's what i need
you
our loyal listeners to do harry's has a
great offer for you guys
new united states customers can redeem a
harry's trial set at harrys.com
h3 for just one two three dollars
you get five blade razor featuring their
all
new sharp blade a weighted ergonomic
handle foam shave gel
with aloe and a travel cover to protect
your blade when you're on the go
all of that for just three mother loving
dollars
just go to harrys.com h3 and redeem your
trial offer
today thank you very much
so tell me about uh dr young if you
would please tell me
uh in detail how [ __ ] up ab is please
well i can tell you that um you know
again three out of six on the
entitlement
questions and uh
on question five the choices are the
thought of ruling the world
frightens the hell out of me or if i
ruled the world
it would be a better place there would
be a lot more lights
maybe one more ambitions to to do you
really you think you're up for that task
huh
to be honest i thought i answered that
in the opposite way
to be 100 honest but see what is with
you guys you guys are all flip-flopping
when you're
not i mean
i think you want to rule the world look
how proper he looks today wearing his
cardigan and his glasses and his
watch what were the other ones talking
okay so um
next one i insist upon getting the
respect that is due me
i usually get the respect i deserve
so he insists on that's what he answered
yeah
interesting maybe
uh i mean i don't know i the way i
interpret it is like you have to earn it
basically
like it's not just given which i respect
so if somebody okay what's the next one
last one is
um i have a strong will to to power
oh my god or power for its own sake
doesn't
interest me you like power you
definitely
it wasn't necessarily about liking power
it's just that in my life
i've always like gravitated towards
leadership roles against
my own will sort of like i see yeah like
i was
president of like the biggest uh
organization on campus i mean these are
all
minor but um which i didn't want to
i was made head manager at a restaurant
that i worked at which i really didn't
want to
make anything hi i'm sorry doctor
don't make me sing don't make me sing
sort of yeah like at the restaurant i
worked there for example i just
i got very close with my uh co-workers
one of them being my future wife
and if i didn't step up and take that
position the other person that would
have would have made our lives hell so
i did that even though i didn't receive
as much money as i did as a waiter
and it was a lot harder to be a lead
manager rather than just
a waiter while in school a.b are you
trying to take my job
stop i'm trying to be your understudy
i'm trying to be your apprentice
yeah we don't we all know the story
about the apprentice in the master right
one trip to croatia and um
one road waving croatian all of a sudden
you have
you have money i
i will like that to you guys i'm forever
in your service can i can i ask why the
cardigan today
i'm just curious this is zach trying to
come back at me for the whole suit
i'm not i'm just i've never seen you
wear a [ __ ] cardigan why are you
wearing a cardigan today
i mean she's a cardigan i know we're in
the presence of doctors i'm trying to be
uh respectable
i mean i didn't come in a full suit that
after dark last
year did you buy it or you want to go
toe-to-toe that's true it's like that
bro
well hold on i mean it's true ab you
have never worn a cardigan did you buy
that for this show or or did you always
own the cardigan
i owned it i have a few other ones if
you guys want to see them yeah i want to
see
i'm fine there seems to be some friction
between them you guys can tell though
that's a [ __ ] synth because they're
both competing for a heartthrob
and i'm married i'm not competing no no
but
but in this i think a b in the same
sense where he's like i didn't choose to
be the heartthrob i didn't want to be
the heartthrob
right right i just chose to wear a
cardigan today
and just cut to ian who is uh basically
in planes of enlightenment
he is disengaged he is in the ethereal
realm of
a new level he's in nirvana yeah yeah
he's in nirvana
so let's talk about dan
tell me about dan's score yeah there are
two other scores we haven't done
one is dan dan got a 8 out of 40.
really thank you you and me baby huh you
mean ethan
and a little more narcissistic than you
apparently one point one point
dan had one category where he expected
dan is a great guy
well thank you mr president so where did
you excel dan
well he uh he actually got a five out of
seven on authority
oh that makes sense read those to me
iron fist
that's actually really good because he's
our he's our producers right we like
that
and that's true it makes sense makes a
lot of sense yeah read me the ones he
he answered he hit narcissistic on
and then who else didn't we read that
yeah so for dan on
authority and again this was really the
only category in which he
uh you know scored significantly first
question
i have a natural talent for influencing
people
or i'm not good at influencing people
wow dan you're blowing my cover part of
what makes me good is people don't
suspect that i'm good at influencing
them the second question i will be a
success
i am not too concerned about success
so wait wait which one i am not too
concerned about
success or i am you will be a success
okay
yes uh the next one
i'm not sure if i would make a good
leader or
i see myself as a good leader um
then let's see
dan how are you feeling authority
being an authority doesn't mean much to
me or
people always seem to recognize my
authority
carbon vibes
that's true though
yeah and that's just uh it's actually
similar to what a b was describing like
i i don't necessarily
uh uh it's true i don't necessarily
go out of my way to try and seize
authority in whatever situation i am but
it oftentimes seems to fall
to me and i've become accustomed to
stepping up to that i guess i don't know
i look i look up to you
i just i just said that in that video i
just said that i said i
admire you very much
you literally just said the same thing
zack and then you insult him for saying
yeah doctors get that i do think that
zach holds
i feel like zach holds more resentment
than he's willing to admit for
being dethroned as heartthrob yeah it's
a little painful
not gonna lie
it's on the rocks though you [ __ ] it
up
and then so so what's up there's one
more question
yeah i would prefer to be a leader
or it makes little difference to me
whether i'm a leader or not
got it that's fine so that's everybody
on the narcissist scale that's everyone
so i think
whereas one of our narcissism scales the
other is part of the dark triad
right okay so on the pure narcissism
scale
i think we all are pretty i think we all
did good i mean
ian is enlightened he's on like ian is
like
out of having an out-of-body experience
right now he's not even there he's like
on
mount everest or some [ __ ] looking over
looking over humanity
yeah there he um is
no surprises there i'm very happy
in ila i'm kind of i i really didn't
know which way you would go but let's
move on to the dark triad because
this one seems to be more comprehensive
this one the dark triad
oh and they called the dark triad for a
reason
so you know
uh the previous show we talked about
both
trisha and ethan's scores and
you know trisha scored fairly high on
the narcissism aspect of the dark triad
and kind of at a middling level for
psychopathy i do
need to say that she did admit
to being on xanax and percocet when she
finished the test
because dr drew was like your results
don't really make any sense
and she's like well i was [ __ ] up on
xanax and percocet and i wasn't really
paying attention
so there is some consistency there in
the scores on narcissism in the dark
triad and the npi
but certainly take the point okay so
doctor do we have any anomaly
anomaly readings here among us
uh we do just in one person well
before you do that there are some
there's some high narcissism
readings on the scale too right mark
yeah yeah yeah
so uh with a b
he did a 3.89
and a high score on dart triad as your
narcissism is a 3.68
oh so av scored high on the narcissism
scale
yeah above the threshold interesting
aby what do you think about that as
someone who thought you were too
you're according to the dark triad you
have narcissistic traits
uh i don't know what are we able to go
over some of the questions
of course so
yeah there's actually a lot but i mean i
think before we we even do that
questions on the dark triad relating to
narcissism
are different from the ones on the
narcissistic personality inventory
so sometimes it's just a question of the
types of questions they're actually
being asked
right so let me try and pull up
so how this one works is you have a
sliding scale of
strongly disagree and strongly agree on
a scale of one to five right
and so so they ask you kind of similar
questions
and then they gauge based on which
bubble you you fill in so it's a
different
maybe more nuanced scale
so yeah that's right not a fourth choice
it's just
i got i got to give up my studio in in
five minutes here so
okay better we better proceed with the
uh
reveal because uh help you guys through
that
okay so do you want to go through these
scores now
or do you want me to just go to the big
reveal uh
first well i'm not sure i'm ready for
the big reveal
i feel like all right that's okay with
me uh but i'm going to abandon you guys
uh i can come back to help if this
doesn't go well
is it this is i'm just i am just
because you you go so negative on these
results
that's fair so just just remember here
let's get a sound bite
of dr drew saying something positive
right well don't you don't have to
i'll come back and say something
positive on another day but but just
remind yourselves that this is not about
being good or bad person
these are these are strategies for being
in the world and sometimes the
strategies
have nothing to do or very little
through with how you feel inside
sometimes
the way dr drew is talking makes me
think that one of these guys is [ __ ]
i feel like dr drew is gonna drop a bomb
on me but
all right
turns out i didn't have the studio and i
thought i did but um if
if you need any emergency for me to
return like uh like
phone or something mark please text me
okay thank you doctor
thank you if you uh have a nice uh
recovery
yeah thank you very much i got melissa
of rivers today on my streaming show
and don't forget every day around three
o'clock you can get it all at doctor.com
doctor.tv
slash doctor drew will will be there
doctor dr do everywhere dr drew is
everywhere and he is coming at you
live all right guys good luck bye thanks
thank you
wow it's that bad huh dr young i didn't
realize there was still another big
reveal
oh there's like a huge reveal apparently
okay so let's start with so we were
talking about ab scoring high on
narcissism on the dark triad and you
were going to
explain his results right i thought what
i do is just
you know there are nine questions um for
narcissism i thought what i do is just
go through the ones on which she has a
high score
okay uh so the first one is people see
me as a natural
leader okay that tracks and you got like
he got a five
out of five on on that question fair
enough
let's see you
[Laughter]
um i feel embarrassed if someone
compliments me now that is what we call
a reverse
scored question you know in these in
these types of survey
in order to make sure that people are
actually reading the questions
we put in a negative and then or score
it
it's just a technique that
psychometricians use
and so you have to kind of do the
reverse of that which means that
he's not embarrassed when people come
with him really
they got you buddy
and then the last one is um
i am an average person but again that's
reverse scored
so he gets four out of five on that
so you said four to five on my average
person and that somehow indicates he's a
narcissist
no he got a two out of five but when we
reverse score i see i see i see
you go to four out of five i see
okay again for for my money the um
the npi is uh
a much wider assessment of narcissism
you know than the narcissism score in
the dark triad simply because
you've got 40 questions on the npi and
here we've got nine
we have a much broader range of
characteristics related to narcissism
you know the different categories that
you know we kind of went through
so how are you feeling does this all
make sense to you i mean i don't i don't
think
i think it all is pretty pretty uh
reasonable stuff
yeah no i i it makes sense i feel like a
lot of it
goes back not trying to but my dad's
sort of uh
my dad's known for being very assertive
and being like the patriarch of the
family so
i try to be a nicer version of him if
you will
so i could kind of see that
now how okay so we have
what it sounds to like to me is one
person is there any other anomalies or
just one person that's way off the chart
and everyone else is average
pretty much everyone else is average um
one
person got in terms of the three aspects
of the dark triad
one person got pretty high scores
on two out of three categories okay
let's hit the drum roll
so i'm guessing i mean it's got to be
zach right
i mean that would be the most logical
seems like the easiest choice yeah i
mean i'm sorry zach but
with peace and love with peace and love
i have to say it's zach
so dr young the big reveal if you would
please
well you're exactly right
i told you i'm joker brained
that's why we love you zach
i think the um when you look at these
categories
i'll talk about them in detail in a
minute um
zach got a 4.2 out of 5 on narcissism
and that's very consistent
with what we already had assessed with
the uh narcissistic personality
inventory
and the a kind of a high score and that
is a 3.68 and he got a 4.2 so he kind of
smashed the roof
off of the elevator
it's a reasonably high score right i
mean what's the highest score you've
seen on that one
is that about it well i haven't
administered this as much as i have
you know the other instruments but yeah
you can certainly
you know the ceiling of course is a five
yeah so the closer you get to a five
you know the the higher it's going to be
that's a really good high
good grade i mean that's that's higher
marks
but so we knew he was a narcissist so
what about the other two
aspects all right so on machiavellianism
you know this is kind of strategy and
cunning the uh a high score there is
about a 3.86
and um zach got a 3.66 so he is not over
the threshold there he's
just below the threshold um
and then on psychopathy oh no
zach i think you'll be interested to
hear this and the average
a reasonably high score is a 3.4 but you
only got a 2.77
oh that's not that bad so why did doctor
drew make it sound so bad
i was i got afraid that zach's gonna be
full on psychopath on me
[Laughter]
it's just that um you know the other way
we
we add these up is we add all three
scores up together
you know a total and so a total high
uh dark triad score is 10.94 if you sum
the three
right across categories and zach's score
across those categories was a 10.63
but again breaking it down we already
kind of had the assessment on narcissism
the fact that psychopathy is low i think
is a
positive very good yeah we don't so we
got to turn that dial down there zach
and then machiavellianism again that
just really means
you know strategic behavior read me the
machiavellian ones you scored high on
all right so zach how are you feeling
are you how are you feeling about all
this
well i have my shrink on standby thank
god um
what does that mean are you kidding are
you making a joke no i'm just i'm just
kidding
um does this mean i have to be locked up
or like
going to prison necessary straight
jacket
like houdini that [ __ ] like you know
no i mean again remember these are just
traits
right uh it doesn't mean that you have a
disorder of any kind
they're just kind of tendencies and um
we have to say that for the npr in
particular these are stable tendencies
but again doesn't mean you're a bad
person or anything like that it just
means that on these particular
personalities and i will say zach that
your scores weren't that bad i mean dr
drew
was leading me to believe that we were
gonna have to like call the [ __ ] fbi
and
dig up your backyard and chat and start
digging for bones
well do we know is that is that the big
reveal
is that the big reveal yeah yeah yeah i
know he's he's the highest
oh well zach whatever
whatever makes you up you're the
sweetest guy now so so if you lost the
title so zach you lost the heartthrob
title
but you won the crazy title i love it
i love it you know i'll do anything for
the show and that's why you're the
greatest you're my golden boy i i have a
question if i may
um i'm curious how ian did on this stark
triad because he was the lowest he was
so low on the other one
he doesn't even exist do you score super
low on the dark triad is it possible to
not even exist
i i i can tell you that um and i want to
come back to zach
and compare his overall score on the
dark triad in just a moment
um ian got a 6.82
overall score when a high score is 10.94
and there you go so super low there too
it's low but
gila got a 4.76
which is a very low score
really interesting ethan you got a 6.54
overall score a b got an 8.88
well he's getting up there borderline
uh just to remind you oh and dan got a
7.22
a little bit high up there dan that was
like the same as yours
but i wanted to note that patricia got
an overall score of nine point two two
on the doctrine
yeah but she was high she was high and
zach had a six
a ten point six three so exactly i am so
[ __ ]
no no no no no but zach exactly please
remind
everybody that zach you were sober and
trisha was high on percocet and xanax
through the last two which she said on
the show i'm not like exposing her um i
was so
so what does it mean that i was low on
this one like what what are some of the
questions that i scored low on
well um let me just tell you the scores
in each category because
it's so low um you got a
a 1.88 out of five
on machiavellianism so not strategic
you're not a strategic manipulative
person
that's good i think yeah on narcissism
you've got a 1.44 out of five
which is consistent with your low score
on the npi
right and then on psychopathy again out
of five you got a 1.44
so these are low
low scores
well below the mean so the overall score
of 4.76
if i'm looking at the data here
there's not too much that really jumps
out
um across other folks
so i think in summary if you look at the
overall total for the dark triad
you've got zach in first place with
you're coming in second and then
ap third and dan actually
fourth ah this is so like i'm
just kind of i mean seriously how are
you how are you feeling zach like on a
real level or
or do you do does this affect you i mean
obviously we're not taking it too
seriously but i'm just kind of curious
uh i knew i wasn't like other people
interesting so uh there's that
so when you say you mean so when you av
is l has
excused himself um so when you say you
knew
you weren't like other people do you
mean i guess what do you mean by that
like how
how did you see yourself as different
than other people
i'm always willing to do something
somebody else doesn't want to do
it could be an attention thing it could
be a i don't know what it is
but yeah i'm joker brain but i love that
i love your joke or brain i'm joker
brained
i'm gonna have to get through life now
it's gonna be a struggle but you know
i'm gonna do it god willing
and dr young have you administered
yourself on these tests
um i haven't done the dark triad of
myself but drew and i have both taken
the npi and how did you guys score just
in fairness
drew scored i think a 16 and i think i
scored an 18.
and the dimensions on which both he and
i score high tend to be
things like authority and
self-sufficiency
and you find that a lot of people who
are
professors or attorneys um
you know kind of who have to stand up in
front of people and lecture
or to be in court you have to kind of
have some kind of level of
authority you know in order to come
across as being someone who knows what
they're doing
right my scores were all kind of bunched
you know kind of in that direction
and dr young i have i'd make this a
mandatory
thing in the day in the year and day of
zoom calls
i like to ask all of our guests who are
sitting on a green
backdrop to turn it off for us ah
as i see you're sitting in a very
studious well-lit library
let's pull down the curve books okay
well let's see
oh that looks great it's better
there's even more books usually it's
like some shitty
rackety like you're sitting on a bed and
this is a
beautiful option i love your yeah
yeah it's just it's very cluttered and
so um
it's a cluttered in a very
because i'm involved with usc sports i
work a lot with the tennis team and so
uh tennis team is the number one tennis
team
that's ever played the sport at the
collegiate level oh
and so i'm there picking up some
narcissistic traits there doctor
[Laughter]
well dr young i cannot thank you enough
for coming in
and administering these tests i'm going
to get your details because i know your
daughter
is a fan and we're going to send you all
kinds of teddy fresh and a thank you
package so
thank you so much i know you're busy
thank you for taking time out
to do this with us it was a great
experience we really appreciate it
oh thank you guys thank you i hope that
it was a little bit instructive
oh yes definitely well i know who to
look out i know who to trust and not to
trust if that's what you're asking
all right thank you doctor thank you so
much thank you thank you
take care guys okay well
how is everybody feeling about that i
guess there wasn't really any big
surprises other than
actually i will say zax didn't surprise
me
ian surprised me the guy doesn't even
exist
the lowest on their record the lowest
on record ian ian's didn't surprise me
i have a theory what's the theory i have
a theory too
yeah something's off about this we all
know ian's cunning
and we all know ian knows ethan well and
we
i assumed that what happened with ethan
saying can we go back and read those
questions would come up
and i have a feeling that ian predicted
that and he was
very cautious with his answers because
if that's the truth
then he's off the scale machiavellian
right this is this is pretty much my
theory is that really
he understood the angle of all these
questions and
he's such a sociopath that he was able
to manipulate everyone into thinking
that he's some sort of saint
well look how he's floating above the
clouds
i i tend to think i mean like
it almost sounds like a-i-e-n took the
test oh
right
[Music]
who took the test ian was it you are
aien look
all i have to say really is that
who'd they say had the did they say it
was the last
lowest score was frankie muniz right
yeah that's right
well of celebrities i don't know if we
can necessarily put you in that echelon
but all i've got to really say is
frankie hold this [ __ ] l major
[ __ ] you frankie you [ __ ] i'm sorry
frankie but
get the [ __ ] out of here i'm the new
saint
i don't know if you are i don't know how
honestly i'm a
saints it's been proven we've got it on
record
i am a saint i am saint slater
saints i mean to be clear though
they did say that an extremely low score
is kind of indicative of somebody with
no backbone
just kind of a wimp a loser you know
they tried to tear down
teresa too and
it's uh and i'm well i won't go there
but
it's uh go where i mean they kind of
no i won't say it you do you have a
jesus christ mentality like
do you do you think you're jesus i'm not
saying that
well it's interesting that frankie muniz
was the other one because
i know he had problems where he said he
doesn't even remember his childhood yeah
yeah
it's like frankie muniz had like like a
ton of concussions and he's me
he like can't remember him in the middle
of a sad story
actually really it's interesting because
ian has different versions of himself we
know regular ian
ain't coveting slave walking in
i mean i have a hard time believing this
[ __ ] because everybody else was like
kind of normal
low i feel like you were trying to get a
zero
and just i wish you would just be honest
and tell us if that's what
happened or not because you're oh it's
always stick like
were you trying to get the lowest score
possible
oh why would i do that well now i
believe that i don't know saints later
i don't know if i believed that he was
trying yeah i'm okay because
isn't the test designed to even if you
try i feel like if i wanted to i could
i could lie on it and get a zero right
but i feel like at some
place they would find an inconsistency
exactly and you'd probably score like a
two
because you couldn't get them all
[Laughter]
all right i'll take you at your word ian
thank you
are you traveling through a wormhole
yeah what are you doing
you're just ascending yeah just
ascending all
time and space those sunday services man
they really got to you
if you guys ever need any spiritual
advice or anything
exactly so zach was off the charts on
everything we we kind of expected that
and what that's what we love about him
but otherwise pretty
pretty pretty interesting stuff zach are
you feeling okay
i mean i'm a little thrown back to the
truth
but i mean
jesus and i'm more satanic so like it is
what it is
you feel sad like what's the emotion
you're feeling
i mean i wouldn't say sad it's just kind
of like
it is what it is you just gotta roll
with it you're just surprised you
learned something about yourself that
you didn't necessarily know
i think it it's you know this whole
quarantined really like
it was very just you know flatlined so
this kind of gave it a little spike
and uh a little crazy from the stir it's
gonna keep me up at night but i'm
looking forward to it give me something
to do
you know what it shouldn't keep you up
at night
looking forward to it that could go back
to the one narcissistic question when
they're saying sometimes narcissists say
they don't like compliments but they
really do so maybe along that same line
of thought
i love compliments what the [ __ ] you
talking about yeah no zack is
every time i've ever complimented zach
he's just very like oh i really
appreciate that thank you that's true
that's funny because
i take any i cannot take a compliment
sincerely
right like i will deflect any compliment
i get ever
like i'll say thanks i learned to be
gracious about it because it's just
annoying when you try to compliment
someone and they're always like trying
to argue with you
so i just say thank us and accept it but
i don't take it to heart i just think
people are being nice
which is weird because i i compliment
people genuinely
yeah which makes it's like um i don't
get it
you should take it personally i don't
and i don't want it i don't want it
i don't know does this affect uh your
viewpoint of me not at all this is
exactly the exact i feel like
it's just it's like a way of um
describing
your character in a way but it doesn't
make you worse or better
it's just kind of like interesting but
it's part of what makes you
who you are and and why we like you i
mean you know
each one here is kind of different and
that's just you
have like the crazy person yeah this is
exactly what i expected
i i think it shows that you can't base
it off that test
that kind of revealed a b is sort of
like a lex
luthor type of character he's trying to
yeah he's a curveball too i mean he's
trying to go under the radar but he was
scoring narcissism
authority he liked famous people
getting close to important people which
is something i knew i'd known because
you're like a fan of everybody and
everything maybe you kind of have like
um
what's it called when people are
obsessed with celebrities
you say that but i have no idea where
you've got that from bro
okay i hate i i
i really don't i mean i'm the narcissist
bro
you love me you love casey neistat
you're always taught you love
michael jackson you never told you that
yeah but i see you doing all the michael
jackson moves and [ __ ] like i know
you have a fetish for celebrities
you do i've heard that i've heard that
once in my life and it was a guy that
i was arguing with that's imp yeah i
don't know but no i'm
you i'm not you are you ha you have a
fascination with celebrity
let me i get i got a good example i seen
walter junior at target yeah and you
texted us all made a big deal about it
i'm like
[ __ ] great it's my favorite show i
didn't why didn't you go up to him
why didn't you go up i thought it was
weird i thought
it was indicative of that what i thought
because like who gives a [ __ ] about
walter jr
he texts us in our group chat all
excited about you guys i can't believe
that walter junior's right in front of
me i was like
this guy's got a problem he also sent me
some like
like obscure creep shot photos of walter
jr
that he took yeah
so you took creep shots of walter jr and
send it to ian
and confidence i sent the ian creep to
creep because i've seen his uh one with
kanye well
that kind of pisses me off because i
didn't get any pictures i didn't get a
picture
yeah what the [ __ ] why did ian get it it
was past 10 o'clock zach was asleep
in the morning but it but zach has a
natural
um habit of waking up for when something
interesting comes up in the chat
that's true it's like oh you guys
talking about porn
that's a good point though i think i'm
i find it interesting that you're not
aware of this to because to me av it's
super
obvious with peace and love with
peace and love i think you're 100 wrong
every time we're going to interview
i don't need to be there i say can i
text you can i go can i work on the next
episode
i feel like i've done that for like so
many of the guest episodes
i mean i'm not saying you care about
every celebrity
there is there's literally i don't think
you care about
every celebrity but there are certain
celebrities that you i think you are
obsessed with
with with celebrity i think you are
there's like six people
including you and ela that i probably
ever care to me in my life
celebrity wise okay you two casey
al pacino de niro
say michael jackson i'll give you the
pacino martin scorsese
yeah and not michael jackson no it's all
movies so why do
you why do you know all the hell jackson
moves ethan and casey neistat get onto
that list
yeah yeah that's like a big makes sense
like all the great
classic filmmakers and ethan and evan
my college years that was my past time
watching youtube watching you guys
watching
okay but then when it comes to like
david dobrik you know everything about
him
you make these very general statements
no everyone knows something about david
i mean he's brutal but you know
i know literally i know zero
yeah like like you know more about him
than
i think this is more about i mean what
industry are we in i think you guys
should know about david he's
i'm a busy man right now you're getting
[ __ ] confrontational he's good for
the show
i'm not saying he's not great for the
show he has a skill set that's great
but i'm just saying i'm surprised he
doesn't know this about himself
no not at all i mean so when did you
learn the michael jackson dancing and
then why did you get so defensive of
michael jackson when i was
calling him a predator okay because i
just i never because i never said it to
you that i'm a fan that's why
i because it's a touchy subject of
course you're a fan
though you are a fan i think he's
innocent
let me practice by saying that i
definitely think he's in he said
the only thing i ever said to you was
about that if abu was on the crew and
the whole thing was going on i wish he
was cause i
really wanted
yeah you know that that's that's fine
but i would have loved to have had
the opposing viewers yeah and your
defense it's it's no one's job to have
you know looking that deep into i mean
every yeah i don't know i don't get into
it so do you
do you guys see what i s i'm saying
about a b because he thinks i'm dead
wrong
i i see it i mean i agree with him on
the pacino and de niro [ __ ]
well yeah but like
exactly i don't agree with ethan excu
you're [ __ ] one to talk dude i'm not
a yes
i mean i i mean most of the time my
views
it's a lot harder to speak when i'm not
just saying yes and not in my head
oh are you okay let's see you do the
[ __ ]
i do buddy let me say something can i
say something real quick
because i know i'm gonna think me and
zach are serious that has the biggest
sweetheart
i i mean i can't tell you yeah i started
how much
this guy's helping me i can't tell you
every time i was freaking out on air
zach has texted me you're good calm down
you're fine don't worry about it you're
overthinking it's probably
probably just strategizing though it's
meche valley
jackson scored low on the manipulative
but like
okay i mean i i don't want to harp on it
but like
i mean ian dan
do you guys see an ab what ethan says
maybe a little bit and i and i feel like
uh what ap saying uh you know we should
separate the two things
because you talking about like oh i
would love to meet these celebrities i
mean
yeah everybody's got like their favorite
actor the favorite director that they
love to meet that that's
completely normal ethan i think is
talking more about
the sliding into the dms uh sort of uh
moves that we know you've pulled on
multiple occasions
i'm talking about i'm talking about
and i have an antenna for this being as
you know i am one of these celebrities
and i always have to say it like that
because it's so silly but
but yeah i'm pretty big deal
hey i'm low on narcissism
now i feel like you lied on the test
yeah i'm just kidding i always do that
because i feel embarrassed to say it
but ap he's there's types of people who
are like
who have these people as role models
they're like super fans right they're
like
simps they have these people as role
models
and that they they are a
fan of them to a much higher degree
than a normal person would be and i
believe that is a characteristic
of that a b has for certain people that
he like
if i may interject a b have you ever had
like a sexual fantasy about like al
pacino
or like robert like just something like
some casino porn or like
no no hell is this question can i hold
on
i think a little flustered
exactly my interactions with you
ethan is how i would be with everyone
else now i
became friends with you and met you
under weird circumstances because you
were like in the middle of this
online war and there was like groups of
people who were attacking me who are
bigger than me
and you were the only one we were the
only two on this side from my
perspective
so it seemed like i was doing a lot more
and i and i am a fan
and but it's not to the degree like
because she's the one who will really
know don't know
i mean like i don't know i'm a fan but i
don't feel like i'm
i'm the same degree that other people i
feel like that's
taking away from their well we're gonna
find out on friday because we are doing
the simp off so
i kind of have i kind of want to do my
presentation to clarify what i'm saying
don't throw the simp off now all right
let's cut let's go talk to papa john
okay let's wrap this up i'm trying to
add another celeb on my list please
papa john is with us he's got a fire
crackling in the back
papa is that is that gas or is that log
it's gas and it's fake but it looks good
it looks great it's so real
i gotta tell you we were me and ela
recently went on a retreat
and we were using real logs and it's
such a pain in the ass you gotta throw
it
i mean you know what i mean gas all the
way are you propane man yourself
uh no that's natural gas we're in
kentucky we got lots of it
so papa is here today first of all thank
you for joining us
yeah because the transcript has been
released
the report has been filed and the
verdict is out papa
and and i think we can all hear and
celebrate and say
we all knew it papa john was
set up papa john
is innocent and he makes a god damn good
pie too
well thank you it's uh it was a pretty
glorious day when that
report came out and hit the media but i
don't know a lot of people
a lot of things but i do owe you and
gila a big thank you
you busted this story 10 months ago when
the chips were down
and um you know i was getting hammered
pretty good with the false narrative
and i was pretty well down and out man i
was beat up and um
you you you didn't quite exactly know
what was happening but something didn't
smell right
and you've got a pretty good sniffer on
you and um you were right on this and
what's kind of come i mean you've got a
pretty dollar dial-abolical
mind you're not a diabolical guy but you
you gotta you know you can think pr
and what they did here is so horrific
and so hard even for somebody like you
or i to think that they did it
but they did it and we uncovered it and
um you know
the truth came out and uh we're just uh
we're delighted right now
so what exactly came out so right the
revelation was
first of all the original call
there's a transcript released now the
original call you were accused of making
racially charged statements right
and so what happened was the transcript
was released and you can read this
transcript right it's available to
anybody online is that true or no
well not exactly there you're sort of
right
um the transcript was held
out of public view because the company
didn't want anybody to see it because it
pretty well
exonerated me but remember ethan there's
now two tapes
the tape when i was on the call and the
tape
that's after i hung up the
um the first tape exonerates me because
what i said was a disdain for
racism it what i said was anti-racism
and what they did they reversed what i
said it ran into forbes
forced printed a bad headline and the
rest of media ran with it
what the dumb asses did they left the
tape running there was a live mic
and they taped themselves and that part
of the tape the second tape
indicts them right and so it's real
clear that it was a setup
and that you know they the comments are
we hopi hefn gets it
let's run this to so and so and take it
viral on the internet i mean
it was a complete setup and the and they
taped themselves
wow so i have access to this transcript
so how do i have access to this
was this they have access to the
transcript
of the lawsuit it's called transcript
but remember we had to file a lawsuit
against laundry service
to get the first transcript out in the
public so people can really
have to dig for it you you dug for
because you know you're following the
story
so but but this is out there if people
want to read it this call transcript
right right the second call the second
transcript
is in the court a law and laundry
service is trying to seal it
because they don't want that transcript
out there so you got papa john's
doesn't want the first transcript out
there uh because it exonerates me
and you got laundry service that don't
want the second transcript
uh the part that recorded them out there
because it indicts them
so it's all tied up in the legal system
but it's a bunch of bs
so now that the transcript is out like
so like this is great for people who are
following the story
but like what does it mean for you
legally
well the right now we're we have a
motion to unseal
the transcript and we should get a rule
in on that any week
well once that gets unsealed and the
public now knows exactly
what was said in the second call they'll
put two and two together and say
my gosh this goes beyond just not
fair or right this is what they did is
darn right horrific it's it's evil
um what do you do from there well you
first of all you just kind of slow down
here and kind of go what just happened
a you have the setup it was premeditated
and it was uh intentional and it was
a malicious second thing is we have the
louis free report
which exonerates us you know it gets us
off the hook
and then the third part to your question
is damages
i mean the damage they've done to didn't
have this wasn't very
this wasn't good for me this wasn't my
idea of a good time at all but
um the what they've done to my community
they left louisville hanging
what they've done to my employees they
fired all the employees and moved the
thing to atlanta so they got
you know they got put out the door you
know kicked to the curb
and what they've done to the franchisees
to this brand the last two years
by intentionally setting the founder up
as a racist
the damages here are astronomical so so
your
next your ultimate goal is now that
you've you've
you're proven your innocence and there's
more evidence coming
your goal is to now take this evidence
and file
a lawsuit against laundry service for
damages
well you have to look at the different
publics you you have the suppliers
which they've actually benefited from
this you have uh
your community which i told you they
lost you have me personally which is
a loss and you have the franchisees and
the employees
um i remember all the proceeds out of
this lawsuit go to charity
um and so i don't get anything out of
this
except to give the money to the charity
uh which is you know
that i just wanted to clear my name
because you know i have kids i have
grandkids and you you just don't want
that on your record because it's
it's it's nonsense um i couldn't save
the employees ethan
i did everything i could uh i knew they
were going to do this to the employees
and
you know they picked up headquarters
they kicked these people to the street
and they moved into atlanta you know we
were here 30
34 years and they hurt a lot of people
and the damage that this board of
directors
and their good friend steve ritchie did
to the employees and the executives here
in louisville kentucky is just it's horn
it's hard
now to answer your question the third
party the franchisees the people that
really
helped me build this company and help
make me wealthy
i am keying this up for those guys
the franchisees are going to be in the
cat bird seat when i get done with this
board and i get done with laundry
service
that you know they come in and say my
gosh
look what the executives of papa john's
did look what the board of directors did
to the company to this brand to the
founder
look at the damage they've done the
franchisees will
own papa john's international for two
cents on a dollar one day mark my words
the day of reckoning the day of
reckoning is here
we are all waiting now now papa a lot of
people
have taken the day of reckoning to mean
a lot of things for example people have
predicted maybe that you
were talking about kovid people maybe
one of your
pizza uh contemporaries passed away
unfortunately people thought maybe
you had uh that that you were you were
prophesizing a day of reckoning
there was all kind is there an asteroid
coming i mean how
deep does this day of reckoning go are
we talking about
the stock prices or have you seen into
the future something
more ominous right now we have a
what we call a grace period because
we're in pizza delivery business and
everybody's
locked up at home with covet so it's
it's you can do nothing wrong in the
pizza
business right now so that day is
going to happen when that subsides in
sales crash
and all this other nonsense that's been
going on that's really hurt this brand
that's going to be magnified with the
performance of the company
but i you know i don't know if it's odd
or i don't know if it's got
look at the last six months i've been
able to sell
hundreds of millions of dollars worth of
stock at a premium because of kovic
my franchisees my partners have made
more money
in the last six months than they ever
had and louis free
the best of the best just exonerated me
from all this nonsense that i've had to
deal with for the last two years
so it's it's been hard but it's been a
great six
months and i i just uh i feel fortunate
now
uh that the next phase the next fade is
when kovitz decides
and all this comes out what i'm telling
you and it really soaks in
what this board and what this executive
team did to papa john's international
what they did to the brand
in my opinion that'll be the day of
reckoning um
we all wait with mated breath you know
yeah i'm looking at the stock price and
the stock price is doing quite
well i mean at your peak as as the
leader of papa john
it's basically at where it was in papa
john prime time but you're saying
i mean how how can you go wrong during
covet like how can you fail as
a pizza company right now right what's
even worse than that
right now papa john's makes half the
pre-tax profit
and trades at the same price now you
don't think that's a shell game
you know you don't think there's some
shenanigans going on there i'll give you
two examples the ceo
of papa john's comes out and says we
have eight million new customers
yet the customers coming in the the
stores are less now than they were three
years ago
see it's a it's a show game we have
eight million new customers well but you
got less customers
coming in so you see that we're going to
open 50 stores
why can't it just be customers who are
ordering online
well that's that as a percent has a gone
up a little bit
but let's say uh three years ago you had
a thousand customers
today you have probably 960 customers
so even you know so it's a show game
they they say we have eight million new
customers
but they have a lot less people coming
in the door
so they have actually have less
customers now i don't understand
what i don't understand your logic
pop-up because people because it's
coveted people aren't going inside
they're ordering online
that well their order online is a
percent about 70 percent of the business
you know that hasn't changed we don't
have any ins
uh in in seating uh a table dining
ethan it's all delivery or carryout so
maybe that
um pre covert was say 65 35 and maybe
it's 70 30
uh online versus uh telephone or
carryout but it's not that hasn't
changed but the amount of customers
ordering has gone down the last three
years
so in order to make make the sales look
better they jack up the price
so the point is that wall street doesn't
have the intelligence to go what's your
traffic counts
in other words the guy says we have
eight million new customers
and the next question is how much is
your traffic up how many more customers
you have
coming through the door and the answer
to that would be
well it's negative see it's it's a it's
a um
it's a bad number it sounds to me like
the day of reckoning
is coming i arithmetic's not an opinion
if you're if papa john so they're just
giving out fake
numbers fake numbers that's a little
strong
i think misleading numbers i think the
real health of the business
the product quality the uh is slipped
the service has slipped the standards
have slipped
i've stopped ordering papa john's i'll
be straight up with you
so i'll be straight up with you i don't
buy papa john's pizza anymore
well uh i don't know how that makes you
feel papa to be honest because that's
your baby
butt it used to be my life papa john's
pizza used to be my life and now i
i just it's not there for me i don't
know how that makes you feel
makes me feel terrible and i i think
it's just
the obvious that the product quality has
gone down have you been ordering papa
john's pizzas
you still have the word i've ordered 600
pizzas
in the last 90 days are you serious
i know exactly what they're selling so
to your point ethan
you have one or two uh you know surveys
that doesn't make you know that doesn't
make a you know that doesn't make a pop
up
i'm captivated by what you just yeah i
mean too so tell me what's your ordering
strategy you live in this area you live
in kentucky right
so so tell me about we've ordered 600
pizzas in probably 10 or 15 states
just to know what's going on so when you
have as much stock as i've i've had
you want to make sure that you you know
you know the product quality is there
and to your point
you know um one example doesn't make a
survey but when you have 600 you kind of
know what's going on
for sure anyway the product has slipped
they know that the franchisees
know it and the the service is slipped
they have no pizza experience at the
executive level
or at the board level uh they don't care
about the employees they just screwed
them over
and i'm worried about the franchisees if
look what they did to me
look what they've done to employees and
then look what they're going to do to
the franchisees the writings on the wall
that the worst place you want to be in
2021 is the franchisee of papa john's
international
that's the worst place you want to be
you're sitting on a keg of dynamite
so papa tell me about the pizza ordering
system
do you have people in different states
and then you guys coordinate
you get do you travel with toppings are
they undercover are they undercover like
does papa john know that you're doing
this
like what kind of mind games are going
on on a high level
no papa john's doesn't care what i'm
they're happy they need the business
yeah no you could you could buy any
service
and go out and spend you know spend the
money and they'll order the pizzas and
tell you what they're serving that's you
know that's just so
you see you're doing it across it's five
or ten thousand bucks to go out and
order 300 pizzas so it's not a big deal
but is it like uh people you personally
know or
no no it's it's secret shoppers
independent you know
people throughout the country that'll
order pizza and then report what you
know what they got
so you're so you're running expensive
yeah you're running some kind of survey
program
like undercover no
no i'm not running i want to know i'm
interested
i'll get you i'll get you the i'll get
you the name of the vendor i mean
there's several vendors
it's a service they give you i see it's
a service you know papa john's used to
do it but they stopped doing it because
it cost money
hey it costs money and b is they didn't
want to see what they were serving
yeah they're like we know it's bad
that's bad
if you don't if you don't measure it
they won't do it if you don't reward it
they won't repeat it
papa what are we going to do so is the
cheese getting away from the crust
as we've seen that don't even get it
started either don't get
i had i had nine pizzas in washington dc
last week and the the operator in dc's
actually he's a colonel he's actually
pretty good and he's they were slipping
pretty bad they're they've slipped
you to your point in don't even get you
know but right now but kova's going to
cover all that up ethan
you know you're not you don't have to be
on your game when you've got a monopoly
and they got a monopoly
what are we going to do i mean it's just
not right i mean you pizza is a sacred
it's sacred and to see this cheese
slipping away from the crust like that
and the pepperonis not being evenly
distributed it's just
it's just not [ __ ] okay
well y'all also um you ought to be
you know me whereas i spent 34 years
of my life building this thing and to
watch this do
do what they're doing to my baby it's
that part you can get emotional and
upset about real quick
i mean it's i mean to know what we had
and to know how i mean we're the best
place to work in kentucky for five
straight years
i mean the best yeah
how's dating life you're gonna switch
from pizza dating
it's good i um i um
i've been on a few dates i had one girl
that i really really liked but um
she broke up with me oh damn yeah
that's the reason she didn't like packs
oh you got you can't come after the dog
that's a deal breaker oh she's doing
like the dog
no he burps and he's got gas and she
didn't like
[Laughter]
i had to make a tough decision well
really wasn't that tough yeah
well papa listen you're a single man you
got a pizza
empire you've just been you've just been
acquitted
and uh you know what let those clowns do
whatever they want with the pies because
you're sitting pretty
you got your own pie in the sky you know
what i mean it's the papa
i don't know what my future is going to
be ethan i just know
every day i'm thankful because it's
going to be better than the past it's
going to be great i don't know what it
is i just know
that it's going to be really really good
and you guys and your audience are going
to be part of it because
we got through this if we can get
through this game we can get through
anything because this
remember ethan i started in a bar oh
yeah i used to get my ass kicked all the
time
i never had an ass whooping like this in
my life
i mean this has been pretty tough bud
but we got it done we came out the other
side a little bit stronger and a little
bit better so it's good
there you go reckoning the day exactly
papa always stays winning that's what i
say papa always stays winning
papa thank you for calling in who's
and i want to thank rob who looks like a
lawyer is rob a lawyer
is rob a lawyer no no he's a pr guy
hey you didn't hit on uh judas you
didn't hit a little ritchie oh do you
should we take shots at ritchie you
gotta take shots of richie he's the
he's the he's the worst hey rob hey rob
can we take shots at richie
you're muted i think rob he's got the pr
guy here
papa can do whatever he wants hey rob
why are you here what are we
trying to avoid talking about
rob is the best thing at all we're just
reporting on our end watch ah
ethan he's he's already had six heart
attacks
really you're sweating right there
well let's start with this you have to
talk to anybody the way i talk to you
rob okay let's start like this i think
rudy or i think judas aka uh
rick richie ritchie little richie i
think a little richie turned a little
poori after he tried to backstab your
ass
i don't think you want to be steve
ritchie right now i'll tell you what
this dirty guy did
he um um he called
our advertising agency right before this
went down and said hey
he and shapiro and said we got to get
rid of john he's a bad guy
then he emails laundry service and says
hey
you know just get him on tape get him to
talk he'll hang himself
i mean he completely set me up i mean
you know
the guy makes six bucks an hour as a
driver last year he made six million
dollars
and he pulls a stunt like that i mean
i've never seen anything like that
did you you know i i think that there's
a movie here to be made
i totally the p i mean this is god this
is i mean this is
this is the e2 the god papa
what was it look at this to your point
look at this
you ever talk about a guy did you ever
talk to him papa
say what did you ever talk with him yet
no no
but but you're right would you ever meet
with him
yeah yeah i would oh of course
you have something it looks like you
have some things to say to him
let's role play i'm him what would you
say to me
listen steve all the franchisees hate
your guts they all know you screwed me
over
in the process you screwed us over and
we're going to let john exonerate you
but you got to knock all these other
white-collar criminals out oh
we're knarking i like it i love this
movie
i love this movie i want to watch it so
are we putting so now we're
now how i see is we're going to put
richie we're going to put a piece on
richie
and send them in to get like to get the
uh
you know the wire send them with the
wire the papa wire the pizza wire
well richie and shapiro set up the other
board members
they you know they're the ones richie
shapiro set up the taping they set up
the setup
and took it down and the other board
members
you know they were a bunch of suckers
they went along with it you know they
panicked and went along with it
and uh shapiro ritchie left these board
members hanging the bag
but look at this look at this you have a
guy that builds a 5 000 store chain out
of a broom closet
in a public board of directors setsiebup
paints him as a racist and tries to take
him down
to where he can't even get up the rest
of his life i mean
that's beyond jealousy and the hatred
that's that's biblical papa
it's evil the franchisees deserve better
papa how long how long ago was it you've
been divorced now how was life how was
your life adjusting
now to i mean just how has that been i
know the divorce is just really tough
and i'm just curious how's it been for
you well
it was um you know a great 27 years
yeah you know um and um you know she's a
great woman
um we'll um it'll be
in two days and 10 hours and three
minutes it'll be a year
since i've been divorced you're counting
down the days pop of jesus
yeah you're counting every second well
is it odd to be
is it odd to be single after all this
time it's got to be a weird feeling eh
quite an eligible single man too i might
say
um i don't odds the wrong word i think
you know i think it's the it's in
everybody's best interest i think
yeah i think she's a lot happier and i
think i'm a lot happier and
i know what's best for her and i love
her and i want what's best for her
and there's no doubt in my mind that
she's happier and that she
this is good for her that's nice i mean
she's she's beautiful she's fit
um kids and grandkids love her
she's wealthy i mean she's got her own
jet i was gonna
my next question was my next question
was how much did this
how much financially did that hit that
hit you pretty good probably at the
divorce yeah but
you know we were partners that's true 32
years yeah so she kind of
yeah she was there with me the whole
time so
you know she gets her cut i mean that's
just how it works but she's wealthy
and she's got great friends she has her
own jet what kind of jet
huh what kind of jet is it does she have
yeah
i don't know i never ask
i don't know where she is i know she has
a jet because she keeps it over the same
airport i keep my jet you guys have
so you're like you know what we both got
jets
come on it's all good
how's he doing rob is papa says pop i
said rob how's papa doing
just checking in on the pr guy divorce
is tough and i just want to check in on
rob rob how we doing
papa's doing great thank you thank you
that's cold for he's nervous ethan are
you guys in the same room
or is you guys as he's on zoom like like
how clo are you guys you just looked at
him didn't you papa
he's in new york okay and so if he if
you're going some
territory where he thinks is unsafe how
does he notify you
you guys have like a private chat open i
don't know i didn't even know he was
going to be on the call
rob why are you on the call
ethan the chance of them coaching me
when i when you interview me
is like somebody coaching you it ain't
going to happen
so rob do you really think that you can
control this force of nature i mean why
are you here rob let's be honest
but turn on your mic rob don't be shy
come on you're on the call what are we
doing here
no one can control papa we're just here
to
watch what's going on
but i mean i got to tell you that it was
i mean you don't know what
that's what a pr how bad a shape i was
in pal yeah
i know i mean i was pretty depressed i
was like no man yeah i didn't know how
to get out of this mess i'm like yo i
have a tape
just listen to the tape for god's sake
and um
you know i just couldn't get the media
to wake up and they finally woke up so
i don't know how this happened but i
feel i just feel really
like a ton of bricks is off my shoulders
i feel like a guy that
got out of jail on a crime he didn't
commit you know what i mean you kind of
get that freedom back
it's a really an odd feeling there's
nothing worse than being first of all
being accused of something you didn't do
but even beyond that it's like being
accused of being a racist you know and
so
because that that's just a really
terrible thing to be you know
it's the worst and people rea and and
people pass judgment have
people really judge you for that one too
so it's like
you know i think i think sadly in a lot
of people's minds
you know it's like they hear it once but
they don't hear the second chapter
yes yeah um it's
i mean i guess you could go to a
murderer or a pedophile but i think a
racist
is probably the worst of all of them and
i i i
okay let's examine that you know say
what
so you so we think well yeah
so being a racist is bad but maybe maybe
not as bad as a pedophile though
yeah i you know i i i agree or a
murderer
but i know what you mean people think
like they say racist
and then like for example let's say
who's a famous pedophile um
who's a famous pedophile who epstein oh
epstein
right so you think that your label of
racism is almost as toxic as epstein's
label of sex trafficking oh i don't i
wouldn't go that far but i can tell you
it's a bad category to be in that's not
yeah for sure
i would rather be you than epstein in
terms of
he's dead yeah i throw in the white flag
on that argument
yeah rob any thoughts
rob would you rather be epstein
or um or uh
or falsely sorry the connect
connection's breaking up
[Laughter]
rob is taking the fed on the epstein
question
how much you pay this guy rob no i'm
just kidding i'm just kidding
well i love you obviously i'm getting
what i paid for right you know you know
i'm just giving you a hard time rob
well thanks for having me papa it was so
fun i always loved hearing from you i
always loved
and i got to say you look happier you
look relieved
we love a happy papa because you brought
so many
great pizzas into my life and listen
nothing makes me happier than pizza my
wife can tell you
i gotta think i owe that all to you the
man with the vision in a broom closet a
couple pies forget about it huh
i tell you what but i love you to death
but brother you got to start
eating the way he literally eats you got
to get on that vegan diet brother
you got to take care of you come on here
tonight no i didn't call you obviously
you're getting advice from
hold on hold on zach hold on papa zach
you know
hit that sound bite about pizza being
nutritious
i was just following your advice papa oh
no
go ahead zach pull the record pull the
tape
oh gosh pizza is actually very
nutritious
i was following your advice papa yeah
but notice the tone of voice notice the
i was kind of in my shell i'm not sure i
was trustworthy in that interview okay
so
hey all sincerity that that um that
complaint
that an amended complaint is going to
get unsealed here it comes in it's
pretty juicy what comes out tell me what
that said
you know they it was a hot mic and these
guys put their foot in their mouth
they indicted themselves it's pretty
funny so i'll send that to you when i
get it but yeah
uh happy holidays to you happy holidays
um can we get back to the uh
i just wanted to hear if you had any
concrete advice for ethan on his diet
oh come on health wild health there's a
couple people there's actually
wild health remember this name ethan
this
wild health bad dog papa john's
promoting now
yeah wild health i i don't own enough of
it to want a shotgun but anyway
um it's um they'll get you
where you want to be mad dawson at wild
health uh
in lexington kentucky uh what made you
rich
and what made you rich pizza
okay interesting but you
i don't know what it means i don't know
what it means it doesn't mean
but but um yeah they'll uh pizza is
actually very nutritious
oh gosh yeah if you just eat one slice
or two that's what i said you you
exactly
how are you it's all about monday this
guy is a billionaire
and he's saying oh eat one or two slices
you don't get a b
become a billionaire by selling one or
two slices of pizza
like come on you got me you people like
me
people that look like me pop art is why
you're sitting in that
pizza mansion with the fire behind you
yeah all right
guys half your size of why i have a jet
guys your size of why my ex-wife has a
jet
holy [ __ ] sorry about bearing
really take care of yourself happy
holidays hilah get him in shape now come
on
oh that's hilarious thanks papa
thank you papa take care have a great
christmas all right i hope you get it i
hope you're getting some weird ass okay
at least
why rob are you still here you want to
say anything rob
rob bounced out fast
we love we love pop man that was [ __ ]
funny i have to say
you know the guy coming here call me fat
but i can't even hear cause that was
he has a good point
i love [ __ ] with the pr people when
they show up it's like
come on well
love papa that was a great
call and a great personality test this
was a great episode yeah this was just a
fun
high level i feel like this was a high
level episode
right i mean there was a lot i mean who
gets calls in from papa john
a tests administered by real doctors
doctors doctors that turns me on
you know what i mean like that was
pretty awesome papa was
apparently found out he's been slamming
which is good
i bet you papa [ __ ] like he probably
goes crazy
in the sack he's pretty fit
you know i mean i bet you papa [ __ ] is
like a monster
that's pretty dope would you like to get
railed by papa's let me finish
let me finish it
[Laughter]
can you repeat that would you like to
get real
i'm not a homosexual oh well that
doesn't make you homosexual just means
you're going to get railed by papa
for the show zach you just asked me if i
have any dirty dreams about al pacino
yeah you did
well okay that's a different that you
that's something yeah there's no porn
where like ginger's involved
and you know what i don't know what
casino porn is
the movie because i know what you're
talking about i didn't know that was a
genre of porn
maybe knows everything about that
doesn't he no i just i it just hit me
when you said ginger's involved i
thought you were saying like red hair
but you're talking about the character
the character ginger yeah is there a
casino
the movie like porn right
i don't know it's probably like the 90s
and
zach i mean joe pesci said eat out my
ass so i mean
eat out my ass
that's true all right we're off the
rails um
okay so uh this is coming out on
thursday so that means we will see you
tomorrow
for after dark which technically is our
last
episode of the year yes sir that makes
me feel
sad i know and i actually don't i'm not
sure that i even want
like i feel sad do you want to not take
a break well i feel bad for these guys
because they deserve a break
maybe we could just reduce our frequency
for
but i think i probably do need a break a
break is healthy
yeah well let's talk about it on friday
what do you say you can let everyone
else off i'll be here
i don't i don't know anyone here so i'd
like to take a break
i i dread i dread the holidays so
i'm down to these shows i think dan
needs a break then it's a break
and definitely does and
yeah i'll take a break okay what are you
gonna do too
you don't even exist i'm gonna meditate
[Music]
hopefully we'll all have ps5s by then
but i doubt it
maybe annoying maybe i won't hold my
breath
because i'm wondering if we could do
something like do some live streams or
something just to
just to have a fun time you know having
some laughs you know
i would absolutely love it i think we
should just take a two-week break yeah
it's not like we're going away forever i
just dread the holidays so [ __ ] much
why it's not it's so depressing to me
you hate your family that much no no
it's not a family thing it's just like
why depressing it's just like most
happiest time of the year
it's like really real happy so you're
you're upset that you're not jubilant
during the holidays and that
depresses you yeah yeah
and it's like you know you just sit
around a christmas tree
what the [ __ ] is wrong with what
happened to you are we joker brainy
yeah i don't know if this is joker brain
or if you got like molested under a
christmas tree
no it's just i mean you can ask these
guys i'll go over there i asked them can
i come over and cry in front of your
christmas tree
okay joker i mean a b can attest to that
yeah i don't have a tree or else you
could come
ian has a tree all right
ian how do you decorate your tree
um very
macy's chic
oh it's subtle we keep it chill macy
that means to me any like uh boutique uh
little
cute stuff on the tree or just like
balls and
we a lot of balls i love a lot of balls
balls everywhere we can't put a lot on
the tree because
our cat knocks it all off yeah we had um
we have a tree in our living room and we
had these glass ornaments and theodore
was grabbing them and smashing them on
the floor
so we had the we didn't remove them we
just moved them up
so the top half of the tree is very
decorated and the bottom half is very
bare
it's uh star david's because it was
saying we should be
boat well i wanted to know more of a
hanukkah
yeah i wanted to know
but he got i got him a tractor and
airplanes too
all right listen this conversation
is uh that yeah so we'll see you on
friday we're gonna have another great
show planned for you
like they all are this is the h3 podcast
it's the only show in the world like it
number 18 in the world or something i
don't know
22 that's a bit higher than that no it
was 22.
i'm telling you it's moved up since
that was like last week yeah and we
moved up it wasn't last week
what's happened just today's episode
moved us up we're number 18 now i just
said it
and it's true all right we'll see you
guys on friday so
um hope you have a great time hey dan
that's not bad
huh all right guys we'll still see that
thanks
to tattoo